[Music]
[Applause]
hey there friends Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain this is another one
of my single take kind of off the cuff
lessons and this one is going to be
around something that I discovered in my
first couple years of spinning poi that
really became my go-to method for
switching the timing and Direction and
just the direction in general of the POI
and that is wrist wraps or I guess we
can also consider these forearm wraps
but before we dive into that I do just
want to give you a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca beckonen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission alright so when I first
learned how to spin POI a lot of the
people that I was learning from were
coming from the glow stringing Community
they were people that had learned about
prop spinning from the Rave or Burning
Man scene and so a lot of them had kind
of learned the techniques around using
wraps to switch Direction in the first
year or so that I was spinning I still
wasn't terribly good at stalls but wraps
were something that I learned relatively
quickly and so that kind of became my
go-to way to change the direction of the
POI if say I wanted to switch between
like a three beat weave and a butterfly
right
um so I've kind of lost touch with doing
wraps over the years uh simply because
like stalls and pendulums became a
bigger deal to me but lately since I
have been playing around a lot more with
glow stringing inspired techniques and
including a whole host of different
wraps and shotguns and the like
um it occurred to me hey this might not
be a bad thing to go revisit so for
those of you out there that are at the
beginning of your spinning journey I
will tell you that raps are a great way
to do a lot of the same things that
stalls do so if you're up for learning
them they're definitely worth your time
so let's talk over some of the basics
here wraps basically involve wrapping
the tether of the POI or like the sock
of the POI as the case may be around one
of the kind of surfaces of your body it
doesn't have to be uh your forearm of
course it could be over your elbow it
could be around your leg you could even
like do it around your torso if you so
chose it's totally up to you the most
common ones that I did when I was
starting off were definitely these
forearm or wrist wraps the reason being
just that
um you know it it's quick and easily
accessible if you're doing other POI
tricks especially if you're doing POI
tricks that are nestled up close to your
body this is definitely a technique that
rewards T-Rex arms as much as it pains
me to say that
but also too just they're pretty easy to
practice since all the pieces are like
super available in front of you and you
can get uh feedback from a pretty pretty
easily and you can keep everything far
enough away from you that it doesn't
feel like you're kind of putting your
face In Harm's Way unlike elbow wraps
which always like they look cool but
they always gave me the feeling that I
was about to hit myself in the process
so let's take a look at these wrist
slash forearm wraps now
um
when I first learned how to do these I
had a bad habit of just like wrapping
the tether of the POI all the way around
my arm and being unable to escape from
it and I kind of compensated for that by
just like yanking really hard on the
tether to bring it back out and I had
somebody who watched me do this it was
just like look you're making this way
harder on yourself than you need to
and the tip that they gave me is still
the tip that I used to this day and that
is that
um the butter zone for this that is like
where you want to hit is going to be
getting the tether of the POI around
your arm to the point that the head
comes around and Taps the tether on the
other side that way all it takes is just
a very very light tug of the handle to
pull the POI back out and switch
Direction with it right if you let it go
further around you wind up in that
position that I mentioned before where
you know it takes a lot of effort to get
back out and if you don't uh and if you
don't get enough of the tether wrapped
around then if you try and pull out of
it the the POI just like kind of goes
dead right so it's this very very like
it's not that hard to find it's
um it really what I find is uh basically
you want to feel as though as you're
wrapping the tether over your arm that
you can just barely feel the edge of the
head against the underside of your
forearm and that tends to be right about
where you're looking for
um
really if you were to like pause as the
wrap is completing this is about where
you want to be you want to get the head
touching the tether on the other side
you don't want it to be able to go all
the way around but just barely starting
to touch it is right about the right
spot and of course once you get there
you just give it a light tug and it
automatically comes back out of course
the same thing works if you're wrapping
around underneath again you don't want
to let it go too far but if you get it
to the point where the head is just
touching the tether if you just lightly
pull out you'll get the whole thing to
unwrap so unwrap
going over and under and over and under
um one thing you might want to notice
about how I'm doing this is that I'm
more or less keeping the distance
between my hand and forearm consistent
as I'm going back and forth that way I
don't have to like adjust on the fly to
get the proper length it takes a little
bit of practice but you can get it to a
point where you just have a feel for
what this distance is and you can kind
of just hang out with your hand in that
position as you go back and forth right
cool
um of course you want to learn how to do
this with both hands so as you did with
your left hand now do it with your right
or vice versa again you're trying to get
the POI to wrap far enough around that
the head just touches the tether on the
other side and then unwrap going around
underneath again you want to get that
head just barely touching the tether and
you can pull right back out of it yeah
under over under over yeah
um in fact I think
um even even like giving it just a
little bit less slack than that can
sometimes be helpful if you really want
to get in and out of this position
really quickly
um
so once you have this down with both
hands you have an opportunity to do an
exercise that I think is really fun that
I did a lot in my first year of spinning
poi which is to go right right left left
right right left left going back and
forth as you can see I haven't done it
in a while
writes right left left or even go right
left left right
going just straight back and forth
between the two right
this is also really fun because it
teaches you some of the basic skills of
switching up which hand is in front like
you do if you're performing a thread the
needle so you know say rights left
right or right left right left right
left right left going back and forth and
you just switch up which hand is in
front and of course you'll notice it
takes you back and forth between moving
the POI in opposite directions and
moving the POI in uh same direction
whether it be usually I come out of this
in Split time I just find the timing of
that works out better but uh yeah it's a
quick and easy way to learn how to do
your timing changes as you're starting
off your POI Journey so I highly
recommend it
um
yeah cool
um so uh thank you out there so much for
watching if you have any requests for
stuff you'd like to see me cover in
future installments of this series also
are you enjoying this series do you like
seeing me give these kind of like single
take off the cuff lessons uh in my
living room here on a more casual kind
of way leave me a comment and please let
me know and also
um of course I am teaching live stream
classes at this point so you can get
more of this stuff from me you can learn
more and register over at crowdcast.io
slash directs Factor POI go check that
out please and thank you
um yeah so uh please like comment share
and subscribe if you dug this content to
help other people find it
[Music]
and of course this video would not be
possible were not for the kind support
of all of these awesome people right
here these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they along with the people
listed down in the description helped to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all so much for yours for your very very
generous support
um
if you out there watching would like to
sign up to support my work and are not
currently supporters you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards including uh a weekly
lesson delivered into your inbox that is
exclusive to patreon supporters it's
just like this one as well as early
access to my content and a whole bunch
of other stuff too so go check that out
please and thank you and if you'd like
to check out some more tutorials that I
have put together over the years that
have a little bit more prep and planning
in them than this one you can do that by
checking out a link to a playlist of
videos that I'll include down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you'll
like this top video here based upon your
past viewing habits so maybe give that a
look too thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow this week
and I will see you with a new video real
soon now yeah awesome peace